[Music]
[Applause]
michael eaves espn sportscenter anchor
and he's doing the interviews live
coverage of the masters and got a chance
to talk to tiger after finishing his
round espn's live coverage second round
of the masters starts at three eastern
today as we bring in michael eaves kind
enough to join us michael at what point
do you start in your mind thinking of
what questions you're going to ask tiger
when you get that opportunity
you know that's funny um mike mcquaid
who runs our golf coverage for espn he
is my uh producer when i'm doing the
interviews
and he hit me right before tiger was
coming in he said what do you think
about asking him i said i've already had
my questions
two hours ago i knew exactly what i was
going to ask them at least let me
rephrase i knew i was going to ask him
the first question and then based on his
first answer i was hoping my second
question would still apply but because
we've known so much about him and this
story dan um
it was pretty obvious what we wanted to
get out of him right was what it was
like for him just being back there and
tiger's always been guarded about his
feelings i tried to get him to to break
that force a little bit he saw the look
on his face when he was walking towards
the first tee i thought that was very um
interesting and i want to get a take out
of that and then also it's like he
always says you know playing golf with
my friends is one thing tournament golf
is something else so like what was what
did you learn in this tournament round
that you couldn't learn about yourself
or your game for that matter in those
practice rounds so i thought those two
questions were
layups and i had them two hours ahead of
time yeah and the thing you got to worry
about with tiger is he can shut you down
with a yes or a no
right and you've given all this thought
to this great question and sometimes you
know as an interviewer we get full of
ourselves like damn that's a good
question
he's going to crush it and then all of a
sudden he goes no or yes and you're like
okay now you got a rally it almost feels
like you get in a situation like that
where you don't want the interview to
end
because you do have this magical moment
and he's giving you things it feels like
he's actually
talking to you
not sort of you know regurgitating
something
did you get
i did um
the the last question i asked him um
was more about you know his body and how
he feels and what he's gonna be doing
you know to get ready for a round two
today and that's where he kind of shut
me down a little bit with his little
things like a lot of ice you know that
was the answer a lot of ice between the
you know the next 16 to 18 hours
but uh what i got from him dan even like
the brief exchanges we had before we
started that interview um
i think he took more pride and been able
to get here and actually play that first
round than the score itself
because
what he went through and i think because
he's been so great for so long and he's
overcome other injuries in the past and
other embarrassing moments as well that
we take him for granted more than maybe
any other athlete we have in our time
because he continues to do it there's a
friend of mine that works at yahoo his
name is al toby he said the thing with
tiger there are no peaks there are no
bottoms there's always more and he keeps
giving us more and we take it for
granted but for him personally he knew
what he went through to get back there
to that opening tee shot on thursday and
there was a lot of pride
that he carried with him as he walked
off the 18th green
do you know tiger's going to come in
yes
yeah there's a request process like from
our position it's either he's going to
come to me or go to butler cabin
and we knew early on that he's going to
come to us and not do butler because the
thing is if you remember cam smith was
in the group in front of him and cam
smith brown was so good he went to
butler cabin so we knew we were getting
tiger if you had one more question
yesterday what were you going to ask
um
hmm i've lost my train of thought
because i'm already worried about what
i'm gonna ask him today quite honestly
if i get a chance to talk to him um i
don't i don't think i didn't leave that
interview thinking damn i should have
asked him this or i wish i could have
got one more thing out of them now if if
seller sly who's the producer for cbs
would give me you know two more
questions i could have kept going on but
i didn't really leave there thinking
damn i wish i should ask them something
but see i liked the last answer the last
answer he gave you is that he's
basically going to be using a lot of ice
to you know reduce the swelling
he did it in a way that was respectful
to you
what's going to be you know the process
over the next 18 hours and he said a lot
of ice so he's he's telling you the
interview is over
but he also
but but he wants to i mean there's a
science to when somebody says something
to your how they say it to you
and you can also tell in somebody's eyes
like um this is this interview is going
to end here and i thought todd gave you
a great answer
he did and he's an expert at that quite
honestly through the years he's an
expert but what you don't a lot of the
fans at home watching don't understand
is in that interview area after me he
then had to do cara banks from the golf
channel but she's working for sky sports
and then when cara was done uh amanda
renner former amanda balionis had to do
another interview with him for the cbs
late night show and then when he left
our area he walked outside and talked to
the media out there so he already knew
what his um requirements were so he was
like all right he's you got three let me
move on to cara right so i wasn't like
uh totally shocked he kind of shut it
down on that last one well good luck
today and uh hopefully you got your your
questions you know i'm gonna be there
watching so i'm gonna i'll send you i'll
send you a text afterwards
hey between you and tom rinaldi who had
this job before me yeah my i'll make
sure my subject and verbs agree all
right
thank you michael good luck today
all right dan take care brother that's
michael eaves espn sportscenter anchor
and uh doing the interviews live
coverage of the masters espn's live
coverage second round later today three
eastern